i think the media has created a lot of
problems with the covid thing a lot of
you know nobody knows if they can trust
a news source anymore
and i believe it's just because you
can't
the news wins if we're all fighting if
we're all sitting there in
fear of covid watching the news to get
the next dose of whatever they want to
say
then that's how they win
especially now when there's like
different news channels and
some of them don't even feel a merit
like it feels like
some of them just i don't know like they
just look so down upon america where
it which is the country you're allowed
to even have the freedom of speech in it
the wuhan lab you know that's coming out
that they say that they've
you know a uh a
federal committee has determined that
there's a lot of evidence that
believes uh the mainstream media was
silent on alarming findings from the
house foreign affairs committee
a probe into the possible ordinances of
covet 19 on monday
despite one lawmaker calling it the
greatest cover-up in human history
look a lot of people have thought that
that's where the disease came from
uh so i don't think
i think this is just an example of
the news puts out what it wants to put
out
and so they're now shaping what you
believe what you know
and that's what's scary
that's what's scary is that the media
can shape what we
what we know
and what we believe they always have i
feel like there used to be a sense that
you could trust them but now there's not
that sense
so of course you're gonna have every
you're gonna have people believing
things you're gonna have people
uncertain what to believe
you can have people trust in their
instincts
that's kind of where i'm at man hope you
enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option
not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one